well in other breaking news this
afternoon the release of a report by the
independent inquiry into child sexual
abuse which reveals extensive failures
by local authorities and police forces
and finds that the sexual exploitation
of children by groups of abusers happens
more than official statistics say
the report which is the inquiry's 18th
focuses on abuse by organizing networks
it looks at six case study areas that
have not been the subject of
well-publicized investigations into that
issue saint helens tower hamlets swansea
durham bristol and warwickshire and the
experiences of 33 children from those
areas the report finds it is clear that
the sexual exploitation of children by
groups of associated abusers continues
to be widespread and happens to a
greater extent than official statistics
indicate it says extensive failures by
local authorities and police forces
meant they failed to keep pace with the
changing nature of this crime
it also found that children were being
sexually exploited by networks in all
parts of england and wales in quote the
most degrading and destructive ways
it's said that there is a flawed
assumption that child sexual
exploitation is decreasing when in
reality it has just become more of a
hidden problem
as well as a reluctance from some local
authorities to be labeled the next
rotherham or rochdale meaning they did
not give authorities the necessary data
on the problem
in their area
those guys ali fortescue joins me now
ali
the 18th report and
damning absolutely damning
once again an absolutely damning report
as you say this is it it has just come
out in the last few moments almost 200
pages long and it makes incredibly
uncomfortable reading you were saying
that some of the most difficult quotes
it says that in all parts of the country
children being sexually exploited by
networks in the most degrading way it
said that there have been extensive
failures and i quote from local
authorities and police who've struggled
to keep pace with change now it looked
at a number of different local authority
areas including uh durham including
bristol swansea in wales and spoke to
more than 30 different children as well
as people who had survived abuse between
2003 and 2011. it's hard to bring you
all of their stories but i will bring
you one of them a story of a 12 year old
girl who was first abused at the age of
12 her perpetrator was imprisoned but
just two years later she was abused by
20 men and then a few months after that
the charges were dropped they were
charged but they were never prosecuted a
few months later she was abducted by
another group of men and abused again so
this report highlights the patterns of
abuse that were happening it says that
too often people who were victims were
being treated like they themselves
were offenders that the perpetrators
themselves were not being properly
investigated now as you say this is the
latest in this broader inquiry which has
looked a number different different
institutions and individuals including
for example lord janet's looked at the
church it's looked at councils like
rotherham and lambeth this is the 18th
report the final one into residential
schools is expected next month but as
you say more really uncomfortable
damning reading about how some of the
most vulnerable children were let down